bom é muito obrigada e pelo convite por
poder estar aqui hoje com todos vocês
com todos vocês e a minha ação aqui hoje
o convite que eu passo a vocês é uma
reflexão a a a reflexão também tem esse
caráter
nós temos pra trás 3 5 de novembro 18 17
16 5 de novembro é uma data que não se
esquece que não se deve esquecer os
moradores de bento rodrigues aqui perto
eles jamais vão esquecer muitos de nós
conhecemos bento rodrigues a partir do
dia 5 de novembro de 2015
a partir das 4 horas da tarde de novo de
de 5 de novembro de 2015
mesmo assim mesmo nessa nessa forma de
encontra bento rodrigues
nós que não eras né não era os moradores
de lá as pessoas distantes de outras
cidades de outros estados e outros
países mas aqui perto aqui perto é
muitas vezes a própria cidade o próprio
nome da cidade era confundido o bento
gonçalves no rio grande do sul na serra
gaúcha
o convento ribeiro um bairro da zona
norte do rio perto de madureira é esse
lapso e se esse desconhecimento
ele não foi
é pequeno em várias rádios a época do
rompimento da barragem de fundão
eu mesmo ouvi dentro rodrigo ser chamado
de bento ribeiro e bento gonçalves
provocando inclusive mais confusão ainda
em relação às informações muito bem esse
desconhecimento e se das outras pessoas
pode ser uma vai ser desculpável
mas temos que é tomar esse caminho e ir
em direção àquele lugar aquele momento e
fazer uma reflexão sobre o tempo uma
reflexão sobre o presente e os vários
passados que estão ali em bento
rodrigues pra que esse luto que está
sendo feito desde 5 de novembro de 2015
e que não acaba agora em 2018 continua
para aqueles moradores não só de bento
mas de barra longa é para 14 baixo e até
o espírito santo como todos sabe em
regência muito bem mas vem do tempo a
terra as águas e sua gente ali aquilo
que não aconteceu aquilo que o tempo não
viu aquilo que o tempo não presenciou a
sirene aquilo que os moradores de bento
ficaram por ter naquele centro de
novembro
naquele 5 de novembro é em que as
pessoas saíram e não amanhecer 16 de
novembro em bento rodrigues
elas tiveram uma quebra uma quebra na
experiência uma quebra no tempo
uma quebra que elas foram resgatadas de
forma diferente através da memória
através de várias buscas e também quando
elas conseguiram voltar à bento
rodrigues e encontraram lá aquilo que
elas tinham mais medo
a destruição
nós conhecemos momento rodrigues no
outro tempo nós conhecemos rompendo
rodrigues muitos de nós
dessa forma destruída
nós conhecemos é gama barra longa para
cá tudo debaixo pela pela lembrança que
não é nossa
a lembrança é daquelas pessoas
aquele passado que elas perderam as
condições de materialidade pra voltar
ele agora realmente só resta a memória e
alguns pequenos resgates e nesses
resgates é que eu vou me até agora o
jornal a sirene número 1 em março de
2016 na sessão a gente explica faz um
glossário sempre da situação naquele
momento naquele presente e logo no
primeiro número quer dizer um segundo
número o primeiro 0 logo no nesse
momento é muito imediato daquilo que as
pessoas tenham passado começou a vir uma
elaboração começou a começou a virar
elaboração daquilo que estava passando
de memória para a história
à medida em que as pessoas conseguiam
transformar aquela experiência em um
discurso através de alguns enunciados
que remetiam o que elas tinham vivido
agora vendo como história
a lama levou perdemos a nossa minha
infância e adolescência que passei no
lugar que eu gostava
ficou tudo soterrado na lama tudo
referente ao passado
esse é o momento obviamente de montador
havia pouco tempo que a barragem tinha
rompido e as pessoas estavam começando a
enfrentar essa realidade que elas não
iam voltar tão cedo para aquele lugar
que sempre foi delas aquele lugar em que
elas tinham vivido a sua infância as
suas memórias
as memórias dos seus pais a memória do
lugar
a memória não só da vila mas a memória
daquele rio a memória daquelas daquele
espaço daquela terra e ali começou se a
pensar nas inúmeras possibilidades de
dar uma um futuro um aí é se a esse
lugar a essas pessoas e há essa essa
condição a condição da memória
a luta foi justamente essa forma de
construção
a luta pelo lugar ea luta pelo tempo o
resgate da memória ele é fundamental
nessa construção do lugar porque sem a
memória e sem essa luta pelo tempo sem
essa luta pelos seus vários passados
passados próprios passados mais próximos
os passados mais distantes não há
possibilidade de encontrar uma
referência pra em direção ao futuro
então as datas foram todas escolhidas de
depoimentos é dos moradores de bento
paracatu e barra longa e no jornal a
sirene que foram é matéria de uma
revista de bastante conhecida piauí
então 30 de julho o dia de são bento é
um dia de referência para aquela
comunidade
o dia 22 de outubro de 2016 e em que as
primeiras pessoas formam que pensam
formar um grupo que retorna àquela
localidade aquele lugar que ela não
reconheciam mas procuravam as condições
de materialidade para reconhecer para se
reconhecerem ali o dia 22 de outubro foi
o primeira noite que o recém-criado
loucos por dento esse grupo passou a
noite é invento novamente então quase um
ano depois do rompimento da barragem
nesse mesmo momento não é nesse mesmo
conjunto de meses nós tenhamos hoje a
construção do tic s 4
o ds4 foi um problema para a comunidade
de bento embora fosse algo pensado para
guardar a esses resíduos para conter
esses resíduos
mas o de quatro ele alaga um texto de
bento e mais uma vez a paisagem
ela é alterada mais uma vez a memória ea
experiência do tempo alterada
então como lidar com mais essa
interferência com mais uma quebra com
mais um estremecimento do tempo esse
estremecimento ele
deu diversas formas não só nesse nessa
quebra em relação ao passado
essa perda de experiência de referência
naquilo que havia sido
mas se revela também nas nas inúmeras
possibilidades que foram aventadas para
o evento como o tremor de terra como o
abalo sísmico que poderia ter havido pra
é então a barragem rompeu em 20 de
setembro de 2017
enquanto um grupo dos representantes dos
atingidos pela barragem estava fazendo
uma entrevista coletiva na casa das
jornalistas
o então ministro da índia das minas e
energia estava em nova york falando
exatamente sobre esse acontecimento para
os atingidos
era uma tragédia para os atingidos
era uma vida que tinha ido era uma
bíblia em paus que eles queriam
de alguma forma tocar o play de novo e
promissor das minas e energia uma
fatalidade e sobre a fatalidade não há
controle então duas formas totalmente
diferente de lidar com a experiência e
de lidar com o tempo a fatalidade é algo
que o passado não pode ensinar a
fatalidade acontece ao acaso
estudos têm mostrado que é mesmo em
regiões que podem é ter alguma
instabilidade
as medidas podem ser números com os
estudos é de sismologia por exemplo
incluindo é profundo de idade de tempo
que antes não se pensava como como
estudos de paleontologia
não indicam a formação do terreno e as
várias cidades que os terrenos
apresentam e ali naquela região de bento
há uma história do próprio solo
quando nós falamos em cidade em vila em
vilarejo pensamos em construções que a
forma que as cidades vivem que as
cidades têm raízes no tempo e junto com
as cidades
obviamente as mãos que as construíram
mas ali também solo
ele é um personagem o solo também tem um
lugar no tempo
não sou tempo da natureza um tempo que
parece suspenso mas aquela aqueles
resíduos não a força daquela lama que
correu no dia 5 a partir do dia 5 ela
veio com tanta força que removeu o
passado também do solo e um solo que
trazia em si também resíduos resíduos de
mineração ações antigas então esse
rejeito antigo vem o transformar o
próprio presidente daquele sol foram
rejeitos sobre rejeitos tão passado do
próprio solo veio interagir com o
presente
e aí como esses moradores vêem o próprio
presente o tempo das daquele lugar
daquele lugar que foi é deles o a vida
toda
a dona bilica por exemplo de pedras é
fia da seguinte forma essa perda
dois pés de jabuticaba 42 anos
sinto falta de tudo mas a marcação do
tempo dell era pela pelo pé de
jabuticaba que ela mesma tinha plantado
mas um sessão é mais uma sessão à agente
explica de abril de 2016 sobre meio
ambiente
a lama arrastou com ela o lugar deve ser
preservado o local em que vivemos que
envolve todas as coisas vivas e não
vivas
esses milhões
essas milhões de toneladas de rejeitos
envolveram as minerações antigas desde o
século 18 que eu inclusive originar o o
lugar e o seu jerônimo tem uma leitura
sobre esse presente que vai se juntando
ao passado dando uma nova percepção
dando umas nova experiência
o desastre possui sentidos diferentes
para quem correu da lama e para quem
esperou a lama percorreu através dos dos
rios primeiro golaço depois o carro e aí
e atingindo do se ateste a leomar correu
600 quilômetros
o seu jerônimo em são mateus
esperou a lama e ele foi vendo as
crianças são a criação dele sofrer a o
curso de agricultura orgânica que ele
tinha feito simplesmente não fazer mais
sentido ea mineira do território
indígena de caieiras velhas em aracruz
ela diante do rio diz que o rio perdeu a
sua capacidade no triste
o rio pra ela era uma mãe ela sempre nas
suas falas coloca essa capacidade do rio
de alimentar com peixes com mariscos com
ostras e ela se perde ela se perde
porque não sabe mais o que esperar do
rio
o rio é mais mãe o rio não tem mais o
não tem mais aquela capacidade o que
será então do tempo do rio
essa região pessoas gentis e o próprio
solo vivem um presente de extrema
instabilidade as próprias amostras que
são retiradas do solo elas mudam com
muita rapidez porque a poeira muda então
se essa camada mais superficial é
estudada
daqui a pouco ela já apresenta
alterações
exatamente por sua capacidade de mudança
a sua dinâmica e lembrando a esse loucos
por bento na yellow terminando minha
fala é um retorno a essa questão da
quebra no tempo né
essa experiência que antes se pensava
a diferença de gerações o now os jovens
não conseguem pensar a partir da
experiência dos mais velhos
e aí se dá o a diferença e se pensa
aceleração do tempo ali todos estavam
diante de uma experiência de quebra não
havia mais nada dali de 5 de novembro em
diante que eles pudessem pensar como uma
experiência como e todos os todas as
vezes que os moradores de bento vão à
cidade qualquer objeto que acho que
achem vira a condição de materialidade
para uma permanência no tempo eles estão
em busca ainda do espaço mas a luta
nesse momento a luta e o luto é por
estarem ainda diante do tempo
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]